[Musica]
l'ombra che inquieta il futuro devo dire
che due anni fa
tutti noi siamo rimasti letteralmente
sconvolti da quello che è successo
è stato veramente duro
pensare a un futuro nell'ambito delle
imprese soprattutto quando dalla mattina
alla sera ci siamo visti da buttare
addosso un stop si fermano i motori si
ferma l'azienda si ferma tutto
e ve lo dico per un'impresa che si mette
addosso degli investimenti delle
responsabilità nei confronti di noi
stessi piuttosto che dei dipendenti
trovarsi di fronte una situazione del
genere
no cala un'ombra davanti cala il buio
ed è veramente inquietante perché
veramente non si sa bene più che cosa
fare perché contro la crisi si combatte
contro le avversità del mercato si
cercano soluzioni ma quando dall'alto ti
piomba addosso lo stop della propria
attività allora si passano veramente
notti insonni come dico sempre ai miei
figli
dietro a un problema c'è sempre un
opportunità e quindi abbiamo cercato in
tutti i modi di trovare un modo per
cercare di andare avanti in questa in
questa crisi che ha sconvolto tutto e
tutti
dico sempre che il lavoro cambia
dietro le ombre di questi anni il mondo
si trasforma ma noi troveremo
un'opportunità perché niente si ferma il
mondo comunque anche di fronte alle
crisi più profonde oggi viviamo nel
momento della crisi covit e quant'altro
ma il mondo comunque va avanti si
trasforma e andrà avanti
guardare sempre oltre le ombre
guardare alle opportunità
noi eravamo di fronte proprio qualche
mese prima dell'arrivo del comite
avevamo fatto un grosso investimento
strutturale per l'azienda avevamo
acquistato un nuovo immobile
avevamo acquistato nuove attrezzature
avevamo fatto un piano di sviluppo
e questo e questo è rimasto tutto
bloccato purtroppo perché ripeto dalla
mattina alla sera ci siamo trovati uno
scenario completamente diverso
avevamo già investito sul concetto di
economia circolare avevamo già
interpretato ancor prima che arrivasse
la botta e la mazzata di stop che il
rifiuto poteva rappresentare una
grandissima opportunità per la nostra
azienda
ma come rifiuto e noi siamo abituati a
trovare
le bottiglie di plastica no abbiamo
tutti la casa invasa da queste bottiglie
di plastica piuttosto che da altri
oggetti di plastica e anche noi in
azienda avevamo cataste di plastica che
erano contenitori di vernice piuttosto
che contenitori di altri prodotti
liquidi quindi per noi era un problema
di costi di smaltimento dei volumi di
produzione e era oggettivamente una
criticità da un punto di vista di
filiera produttiva quindi abbiamo capito
che oggi la tecnologia ci dava
l'opportunità di trasformare questo
rifiuto che mentalmente siamo abituati a
vederlo come qualcosa di negativo
qualcosa di improduttivo la parola
stessa rifiuto c'è qualcosa che si getta
ecco grazie alla tecnologia
che ci ha permesso devo dire di
proseguire di salvarci abbiamo trovato
una macchina per lo stampaggio
tridimensionale che aveva la possibilità
di triturare questo materiale è di
trasformarlo in un filamento di
produzione un filamento di produzione
che ci permetteva di realizzare dei
caschi degli oggetti di design più o
meno grandi addirittura li ama stampa le
cose di un metro per un metro quindi uno
una rivoluzione da un punto di vista
proprio di tecnologia queste macchine
ovviamente sono tutte a controllo
numerico il grosso vantaggio è che
riuscivamo a
recuperare tutto ciò che era rifiuto la
stessa cosa l'abbiamo fatto con il mero
polistirolo che noi utilizziamo per le
nostre realizzazioni
anche questa scritta è realizzato con un
materiale particolare e noi facciamo
come vedete gran parte dei vuoti tecnici
delle scritte sarebbero risultate come
scarto industriale come costo per
l'azienda e allora anche in questo caso
abbiamo studiato un sistema per
recuperare lo scarto il rifiuto
l'immondizia mi viene da dire quello che
concettualmente abitualmente siamo
orientati a trovarlo come un problema
invece l'abbiamo trasformata in
opportunità questo è il vero cambiamento
dall'ombra alla luce e queste mere
bottiglie che andavano a finire la
spazzatura ingombrando creando costo e
quant'altro
si trasformavano come vedete in oggetti
di design e questo per noi è stata una
chiave di svolta questo lo avevamo già
messo appunto
qualche mese prima che arrivasse il
comit
per fortuna
abbiamo capito
che queste calotte questi vasi queste
lampade questi vassoi che facevamo
potevano diventare anche altri e allora
grazie al mio staff grazie ai ragazzi
che lavorano con noi architetti designer
ci siamo adoperati molto velocemente per
un processo di conversione di
riconversione molte aziende che facevano
tessili si sono specializzate nel fare
mascherine noi che facevamo oggetti di
design dovevamo pensare qualche
cos'altro noi che facevamo economia
circolare dovevamo pensare qualche
cos'altro è allora quello che
scherzosamente
anzi ve la racconto proprio com'è andata
avevamo una calotta di un paralume sulla
scrivania che stavamo studiando
nel pianto generale quando è arrivata la
circolare ministeriale che dovevamo
stopparsi provocatoriamente ho detto ma
perché non trasformiamo questa calotta
in un casco di areazione
ventilata e controllata proprio in un
momento storico così drammatico ecco
allora che ci siamo inventati questo
casco che si chiama casco area
ci siamo messi subito in contatto con le
strutture ospedaliere grosseto e
campostaggia abbiamo cercato
approfondito trovato la soluzione da un
punto di vista tecnico per far sì che
questo casco potesse garantire la
reazione controllata ripeto ai pazienti
e potessero
mettere appunto la terapia domiciliare
vi confesso che non ne abbiamo venduti
molti di questi caschi perché le lobby
nel campo medico sono veramente
difficili da superare però questo ci ha
permesso velocissimamente di rientrare
in moto con l'azienda e di non fermarsi
e di riconvertire mettendo appunto
questa tecnologia di produzione grazie
all'utilizzo e alla riconversione di
quello che era un semplice scarto
domestico questo credo sia veramente una
grossa opportunità se ci fossimo fermati
a piangere sul momento drammatico che
stavamo vivendo sarebbe stata una
catastrofe per tutti quindi abbiamo
trovato la soluzione abbiamo guardato
oltre l'ombra abbiamo visto la luce
c'erano altro problema da affrontare
cambia ma anche il modo di relazionarsi
in azienda perché sapete bene che di
fronte al co lead tutto cambia relazione
a distanza e quindi c'era bisogno di
riconvertire completamente quello che
era l'assetto operativo fisico e
gestionale
tutto quello che è stato amministrazione
e commerciale
abbiamo dovuto rivoluzionare quindi per
fortuna è arrivata la famosa io la
chiamo rather relazione a distanza
perché non solamente da the per
didattica a distanza o altre acronimi
che vengono utilizzati con questo
concetto smart work qualcosa a me piace
chiamarle rade relazione a distanza
quindi tutto ciò che l'amministrazione
lo abbiamo delegato in smart work
lavorando da casa che è la cosa io ho
avuto un'esperienza in consiglio
comunale ne parlavo di questo concetto
credo dieci anni fa ma mi vedevano come
un extraterrestre io dico alla ragazza
dell'amministrazione cosa diavolo ci
viene a fare in ufficio quando puoi fare
questa cosa comodamente da casa con
tutto quello che la tecnologia oggi ci
offre è inutile lavorare in un ufficio
spostandosi e
con tutto quello che ne consegue quando
ci sono attività tranquillamente che
possono essere svolte anche su questo
palco paradossalmente così come le
relazioni commerciali sono completamente
cambiate non c'è più la gente che va a
bussare alla porta del
rivenditore ma oggi la relazione si
organizza tramite una conference call
tramite un contatto digitale sta
cambiando il mondo siamo nel pieno di
una rivoluzione e in questa rivoluzione
noi dobbiamo solo trovare le opportunità
perché se ci concentriamo sulle
opportunità avremo delle soluzioni
diversamente rischiamo che il mondo ci
travolga e ci cado addosso quali sono i
vantaggi della rudd e la riduzione degli
spostamenti sui luoghi di interazione
ovviamente risparmio energetico
risparmio ecologico pensate quanto si
risparmia e quanto si risparmia
da un punto di vista economico ecologico
maggior autonomia nello svolgimento
della propria attività di interazione
lavoro studio relazioni ormai possiamo
comunicare con l'altro capo del mondo
con estrema facilità grazie a un
semplice smartwatch no chi è che non ha
questi dispositivi oggi ne siamo invasi
in tutte le case dobbiamo utilizzarli al
meglio
minore necessità di ricorrere al
rispetto degli orari quanto è bello
lavorare quando si vuole e dove si vuole
con chi si vuole purché si mantengono e
si rispettano gli obiettivi questo è
quello che io ho detto sia commerciale
che amministrativo detto tu lavora pure
quando vuole l'importante è che a fine
mese ha registrato le fatture hai fatto
le fatture hai fatto la contabilità
ordinaria se poi lo fai di notte di
giorno a me poco importa l'importante è
raggiungere gli obiettivi quindi lo
smart working offre questa grandissima
opportunità
possibilità di ottenere risparmi
economici come bendetto riduzione dello
stress e perché quando uno lavora quando
vuole con chi vuole secondo me si riduce
lo stress e aumento della produttività
quindi in sintesi e in conclusione
quello che mi piace sottolineare di
questa mia esperienza ripetono nella
capacità nella
autorità di potermi
ergere a insegnante di qualcosa ma mi è
piaciuto portare la mia esperienza e
portare il mio messaggio che oltre le
ombre bisogna guardare sempre alla luce
non tanto al cono di buio che si crea
con l'ombra
se noi abbiamo questo atteggiamento
mentale sono certo che abbiamo la
soluzione per dire al meglio e per
vivere un mondo che si sta trasformando
offrendo grandi opportunità io vi
ringrazio per l'attenzione vi auguro il
meglio di quanto la vita vi possa
riservare e guardate sempre alla luce
non tanto all'ombra grazie a tutti
[Musica]